welcome back you're watching Al Jazeera
mind of our top stories this hour
there's a near total shutdown of
Internet and mobile networks in Sudan on
the 10th day of violence between the
Army and the paramilitary rapid support
forces the fighting has cut off access
to electricity food and clean water for
much of the population
and the chaos in sudanes triggered the
evacuations of foreign diplomats and
their families the U.S the UK France
Germany and others have pulled their
people out
we can speak now to Dr Syed Muhammad
Abdullah he is the president of Sudan
doctors Union the Canada division he
joins us now from Cairo thank you so
much sir for taking the time to speak to
Al Jazeera so as a member of the
Sudanese doctors Union what are you
hearing about the latest situation in
Sudan
yeah the situation thank you for having
me first and
the situation is is very there
to see it is so bad especially at the
hospitals and uh we are having about 69
percent of our Hospital
yeah at this conflict area they are
totally uh not working out of work
out of uh 79
hospitals in that conflict area only 50
55 has been out of
and all the those left 22
those Hospital working are still just
working for most most of them are just
for the first aid
and uh we have about 19 hospitals have
been falsely evacuated from the and they
have been used as a military base or for
both fractions so the situation is there
and the an apologies doctor if I get you
to repeat yourself because the line is
not very clear how how many hospitals
are actually available as we speak the
people can access for healthcare
yeah
yeah only 22 hospitals in this conflict
area
out of
79 right these are they are not working
fully they are not fully worked because
of the shortage of the clean water
outage of the electricity and we have
about 19 hospitals that has been falsely
evacuated and being used as the military
boys right so they're actually being
used used by the military as bases and
what is your understanding of the latest
casualty figures from the fighting
as you know we uh we are receiving
reports from these hospitals
about only the civilian casualties so so
far till yesterday we are having about
273 civilian deaths and we are having
about
1579 injured these are not included
those who cannot reach this Hospital
right so the figure could be higher
including the military okay now I
believe you have family in Sudan who are
in the process of fleeing to join you in
Egypt are you in touch with them we
understand Communications are pretty
much non-existent so if if you are
talking to them what are they saying to
you
uh can you repeat again the last part of
the question I believe you do have
family in Sudan are you in contact with
them
yes I do from time to time
and some of them are leaving to to Egypt
including my nephew and some friends
families and and how do they intend to
reach reach Egypt because I understand
it's quite difficult now to even uh to
leave the country
yes they are living by buses or by cars
uh they are heading north towards uh bus
one you know this one so the borders
house to first one city
that are the uh the High Dam Area so
they they can approach that the only way
they can can reach to Egypt and just
returning to the situation regarding the
medical facilities and the hospitals you
say even though hospitals that are open
uh don't have access to water and so on
what is it that they desperately need
what is it that those facilities need
that could allow the situation to
improve a little bit
yeah they need they need the Personnel
medical personnel because those who are
been working they have been working for
for many days and they have been
exhausted and they need to be replaced
that's the ferathon but uh unfortunately
there is no guarantee that they can
reach safely the second thing is the
there is the outage of electricity I
have been talking here two days ago with
one of my colleagues they are sometimes
operating using their the lights of
their mobile phones and they are using
very primitive uh ways to disinfect like
this uh the cleaners and and these
things they lack everything and uh so
they need everything you can imagine
they need clean water they lean
electricity they need a medical
personnel to replace those who are
working and by the way I I I really
appreciate what the the great work my
colleagues and all the medical staff
are doing despite all these their
situation indeed a very difficult
situation I really hope your family gets
safe back to you in Egypt good to speak
to you Dr Syed Muhammad Abdullah
president of the Sudan doctors Union the
Canada branch
um
thank you thank you for having